Although
tequila dates back only a few hundred years,
people have long used the heart of the agave
plant to make delicious, alcoholic beverages.
Maguey (Agave)
Cultivated from at least as early as 200 A.D.
by the Zapotecs of the Oaxaca Valley of southern
Mexico, the maguey has been essential to life
for well over a thousand years.
Providing the raw material for building homes
and able to be converted into clothing and
even rope, the numerous species of maguey
(also called agave and the “century plant”)
were an invaluable source of fiber for those
living in the arid, rocky highlands.
In addition, since agave stores juice in its
heart, for well over one thousand years, people
have used it as a food and liquid source,
as well as transformed it into an alcoholic
beverage.
(Yes, Native Americans had many alcoholic
drinks long before the Europeans arrived,
contrary to popular belief.)
Notably, by the time of the Aztecs (14th-16th
centuries), it had been discovered that maguey
offered an effective cure for both gonorrhea
and syphilis, as well as other infections.
Pulque
Since ancient times, the liquid from the maguey’s
heart, sometimes called aguamiel (honey water),
was traditionally collected from the head
and fermented without heating, but simply
through the introduction of natural yeasts.
This basic process resulted in a drink with
an alcohol content of between 4-8%.
Still made today, depending on the mixture,
it can be sweet and fruity or a bit sour.
Many believe it is a rich, and enjoyable,
source of niacin, thiamine, riboflavin and
pantothenic acid.
Reputed to have been discovered by the goddess,
Mayahuel, pulque is also associated with another
400 rabbit deities, collectively called the
Centzon Totchtin.
This large number of gods is thought to represent
the “infinite number of forms intoxication
takes.”
Mezcal
When the Aztecs were conquered in the 16th
century, the Spaniards also brought (and shared)
the process of distillation, by which the
fermented pulque was heated, and the vapors
captured, cooled, reconstituted and collected,
resulting in a stronger and purer alcoholic
beverage – mezcal.
The name is said to derive from a Nahuatl
term, metl or mexcametl, and unlike tequila,
which can only be made from the blue agave
plant, mezcal can use any of 11 types of the
different maguey found in Oxaca, including
Mexican, blanco, azul, largo, pasmo, tepestate
and quishe.
At first mezcal was called a variety of names
including agave wine and mezcal brandy, before
simply mezcal was settled upon.
Tequila
Protected due to Mexico’s participation
in the World Trade Organization, the Paris
Convention for the Protection of Industrial
Properties, the North American Free Trade
Agreement and other international treaties,
the word “tequila” may only be applied
to a particular type of mezcal made in a particular
place.
Under the control of the Tequila Regulatory
Council (CRT), only the spirit made in the
Jalisco state in west-central Mexico, and
only that distilled from the juice of the
Agave Tequiliana Weber plant (blue agave),
may officially be labeled “tequila.”
The origin of the word is lost in time, but
many believe it cam from a Nahuatl term or
phrase that alternately meant “the place
where they cut,” “the place of work,”
“the place of wild herbs,” and “the
place of tricks.”
Tequila is also the name of a town in the
state of Jalisco that was officially established
in 1666.
Although there is some dispute, most sources
point to Don Pedro Sánchez de Tagle, the
Marquis of Altamira, as the first person to
mass produce tequila, beginning about 1600.
However, it was not until 1795 that Don José
Maria Guadalupe de Cuervo was the first to
receive a license to make it from King Ferdinand
IV of Spain.[1]
Don Cenobio Sauza was the first to export
to tequila to the United States in 1873 when
he shipped 3 barrels of it to El Paso, Texas.[2]
This was soon followed by a shipment from
Don Cuervo, as well.
Tequila became much more popular in the US
during World War II, when importing whiskey
from Europe became very difficult.
In fact, the 6,000 gallons of tequila imported
in 1940 had grown to 1.2 million gallons by
1945.[3]
Today, many credit Jimmy Buffet and his song
“Margaritaville” with ensuring tequila’s
place in the pantheon of America’s most
beloved spirits.
The Worm
Officially, only mezcal is supposed to have
the worm, which itself is a caterpillar of
the mariposa (butterfly).
Known as gusanito and gusano de maguey, it
feeds on many varieties of the maguey plant.
Its origin in mezcal is not clear and some
say that the tradition dates back to Aztec
times when the priests would add the worm
to batches of pulque.
Others believe the practice started later,
simply as a means to test the strength
of
the distilled mezcal.
Consumers who prize the worm believe its color
to be an indicator of quality.
The red worm, which lives in the heart and
root of the agave plant, is said to denote
a higher quality mezcal when compared with
the white or gold worm, who is stuck living
out
on
the maguey’s leaves.